what's up this is Grayson Boucher better
known as the professor check me out on
the bootleg Kev podcast let's go
podcast
Street hoop Legend
Tick Tock Legend now YouTube Legend now
oh presser hey let's go man glad to be
here bro yeah it's crazy because I
remember watching you back in the day
man like uh
you know when I was a kid I loved and
one's mixtapes I remember uh you know
obviously rest in peace to Escalade uh
big bro Skip to My Lou who ended up in
the league Rafer Alston uh hot sauce
yeah there's all these guys that were
like celebrities all the big Bros yeah
yeah and then like the and one [__]
influenced so much [__] in culture
because like without and one there's no
NBA Street you know what I mean they're
baggy shorts yeah the baggy shorts just
like there was just so much that like
you know I feel like uh and then anyone
ended up in Walmart you know what I'm
saying which kind of made it uncool but
yeah one yeah you know new ownership I
think it changed hands
five times or something since I was
there yeah so it's in the hands of
ownership now that you know has it in
Walmart I guess they probably hey
they're winning a lot of fun they're
good they're making a ton of money
you're seeing what Shaq did right so I
think it's Shaq and and one is like the
two head sports brands of Walmart so I'm
sure they kill it from a financial
standpoint I was gonna say you were 18
when you started doing uh the N1 stuff
right yeah you know three oh three so
how did you initially because obviously
you're very good at basketball
so at what point in time did you say
well I don't know if I could make it to
the league but this is something this is
like an ulterior or not an ulterior but
alternative uh route I could go to be a
professional Hooper
uh so so initially I came out there I
was really like a fan it just kind of
happened on accident but I always trying
to make the NBA right right but I was
actually a benchwarmer at a community
college so it wasn't it wasn't gonna
happen it wasn't looking great for me at
that moment but after my freshman year
in college I improved by like 300 like
it's crazy I finally hit the weights I'm
playing every day with guys who are
going D2 and D1
I already spent all my time hooping but
now I'm doing three days right you know
I mean like literally make 500 jumpers
before class go to class
230's open gym yeah hit the weights come
work on your game again in the evening
either at a different view non-stop or
right there so now stop so I dedicated
even more time
to the grind and improved I didn't
realize how fast you could improve by
the end of that spring after my freshman
year I was like the best player in the
gym you know I mean with my with my
teammates and stuff like that but then
and one came
and the year before I went to and when
the first the first uh Nationwide tour
they had it was already popping yeah
they had season one on ESPN already I'm
a fan I'm actually wearing anyone head
to toe before I'm even on there like
culturing it trying the moves everywhere
I go yeah so
uh I go up there's a fan just to watch
but I knew they had an open run because
I had played the year before and I got
to play one game against the players I
think I was going against like sick with
it at the time wow a headache those guys
were up there so
hopped in the open run got some moves
off some people were going crazy got
voted in to play against team Man one
and mind you I'm not even thinking the
route of Streetball I actually don't
even think I belong there to be honest
because it was such like a a hood in the
city right you know what I'm saying like
you're just like scrawny little white 18
year old kid yeah I was just talking to
half man half man half amazing the other
day and he was telling me you know we
were talking about the Streetball versus
the NBA debate but remember he was in
the limo he's like yo we need to see
that commercial member the hood
All-Stars versus the NBA All-Stars I had
a pair of those Vince Carters I think
they were called the half man half
amazings the Vince Carters were like the
and ones that were like one one half
color one way yeah Tai Chi yeah those
are hard they gave they gave Vince
Carter that name from him though from
Anthony I didn't know that word half man
half amazing yeah I think Kenny Smith
took bit he knew half man amazing
streetballer but gave it to wow yeah I
remember he was a little upset about
that but right anyway we were talking
about that that uh the debate you know I
didn't think I was a hood all I didn't
think I could be in the mix with the
hood all-stars so like I'm doing it from
a fan standpoint
you know I played next thing I know I'm
going back and forth with hot sauce in
the in the main and one game and then
they asked me to go on tour so mine kind
of happened on accident but I did try to
pursue the NBA up until 2007 played in
the wow CBA which was like the G League
yeah and then uh the original G League
the original g-league that's how high I
got but then like man the politics of
the game though I lost some good when I
got in the game when I they I think they
got me there for ticket sales yeah
because you were a name bro like you you
ended up kind of being like the like
kind of the face and one for a minute
you know yeah so I got there I think it
was like a ticket sale thing but then
like I got a little time when especially
when the starting point guard it was
actually Stephon marbury's brother he
got injured for like three games so I
started for three games one of them I
had over 20 points and like seven
assists yeah the other two I had like 15
and five or something like that we lost
one and one two but when that dude got
healthy man they put it right back in
the lineup even though we weren't
winning a game before that right so it
was like the politics of the game you
know people looked at Streetball
actually in that time it was like it
actually wasn't real basketball so it
didn't fit do you think it like worked
against you because people perceived you
as a street baller and not our actual
like you know professional yeah yeah
when it came to the conventional game
game right it was a bad thing skip to
Malu even you know who played in the NBA
for over 10 years it took him a while to
get in though but he had to let go of
his Streetball reputation I remember my
year getting on the tour 2003 was the
last time he even played any games he
just stopped playing on the tour he had
a solid uh career too and he had some
good years with Orlando and Houston like
yeah he was good but it's cool because
it's actually funny how it works because
back then it was a bad thing to the NBA
high-ups now
the All-Star the Hall of Famers of today
grew up watching and one so like when I
meet you know like Paul George or Kyrie
they're like oh yeah you're my I watched
you back inspired by you yeah love it
it's incredible I grew up off you that
shit's so crazy it's it's wild too
because like think about like NBA Street
they took so many of your guys's moves
and put them into that game yeah did
they ever like tap in with y'all like or
like because it they really took y'all's
moves and like literally it was just I
mean a legendary video game but I can
only imagine it's almost like with the
fortnite dances some of these dancers
you can turn on fortnite the dances are
in the game and then getting credit like
did y'all get any credit for any of the
NBA Street [__] uh people would mix it
up you know like they'd ask us they
think it's our game so we had two games
too so we I remember Street Hoops they
weren't great yeah I think what happened
was I remember the games yeah I think
was Street Hoops they probably saw that
and we're like oh we could do this
better yeah put the NBA stamp on it's
probably gold yep but then we came we
did and one street ball I actually
thought that was DC with Activision that
was a more I don't know if I play that
one yeah so that was a souped up version
but uh it was right around the buyout
from everyone so I don't think got the
marketing boost and I don't think they
were gonna do a part two but it got
bought out yeah so uh I think honestly
they just saw the wave of it in the NBA
smart for them to capitalize on the
street side of things yeah it's crazy
because the tour was like I got to go to
one of the tour stops
um and it was in an arena it was packed
the [__] out you guys had like it was it
was like what was like touring because
it's almost like being on the road right
like if you're in the league but you're
it's but it's a little different because
you guys are kind of like the new H
Harlem Globetrotters in a sense you know
what I mean like it's an entertainment
there's basketball but there's also like
we have to entertain all these people
would you guys like
Let each other get your [__] off no it
was always a real thing it was always
like real defense being played playing
strangers so we didn't know them yeah
because it was T-man one versus whoever
was best of that City in the city right
yeah yeah so there'd be like but it was
it was actually like a very high level
competition game you know there's a lot
of like myths of what level the M1
players were at but like it's a pro
level you know this is above college
this is like a program thing so we would
play dudes who played overseas we would
play like Streetball Legends in that
city right and uh it was real you know
like that was the beauty of it though it
was like
there was even times where it didn't go
our way but most the time 80 90 of the
time we go crazy and honestly that
original group was like special for the
talent level was crazy that's crazy man
um for you you've had such a great like
Resurgence because I feel like you know
I was just at NBA con and uh my sons I
took my kids there and they're they're
both they both played basketball and
they're both like
wrapped up in I didn't know there was
like this YouTube world of basketball
like YouTubers yeah I was the first
YouTube Hooper on accident yeah I didn't
see I didn't know anything and we met
some other immunity what's this white
kid named Jesse T Jazz t-jazz Tristan
that guy yeah so we like my kids freaked
out because he's walking by and I just I
don't know who the [__] this guy is
right so I'm just like hey buddy
apparently my kids know who you are you
mind if they get a pic he's like sure
sweet kid yes I didn't realize this
dude's lit like yeah yeah like I had no
idea because I'm on YouTube I link up
his channel like Jesus Christ like it's
crazy that basketball related content is
so big now and and what you do is so
like
perfect for today's landscape like for
you like you've you've kind of been the
only guy I've seen from the era of and
one that I watched that is successfully
transitioned into being extremely
successful in today's climate like for
you like did was it on accident what's
on purpose like explain to me like kind
of like the Run you've been on a little
bit of both you know like and one ended
in uh oh wait what you gotta think I'm
only 24 25 years old so like I feel like
it's still a playing career right but I
found out about YouTube when it came out
like 04 you know like we would even go
overseas and people would approach me
and be like you know show Love or
Whatever out of habit I'd say hey thanks
for checking out the show yeah for me
our ESPN show and they'd be like oh no I
saw yourself on YouTube so I started
looking into it about 0-405. because
your Clips are up there yeah so they
would rip our clips from the show put
them on their own channels make a
compilation Millions every single one
had millions of views so I got a homie
who was an editor who's from like you
know my home City and I paid him a
little bit where are you from I'm from
Kaiser Oregon very small town man yeah
but uh
anyway well I lived here 20 years but
right from Oregon originally but anyway
I tried to flood YouTube to get bookings
you used to be able to get a DM on
YouTube so I started trying to flood it
like that but then when anyone ended in
08 started my own channel because
YouTube AdSense just came out I think
0809 yeah so I started my own channel on
nine so you're up you're early yeah and
I was like knowing that I could get
International bookings because while and
one went down in the U.S in popularity
once it got bought out and not on ESPN
overseas it was like lit and the social
media and that you know before social
media you couldn't really keep up with
The Narrative of a different country so
they're thinking it's still like topped
off so I would play in like and one you
know Brazil
uh and one Africa wow yeah I was doing
these one-off games so I built YouTube
to get live show bookings wow but then
I went viral like a million Subs in like
one day
what the [__] what video was it it was a
Spider-Man basketball
I dress up as Spider-Man suit yeah I
play people one-on-one at the park and I
think I've seen and I did it for like 20
minutes but I made every shot every
trick worked uh so it just was perfect
edited that joints that's a three minute
video but you know back then it was so
it was a six mil in a week yeah but back
then that was like 50 mil in a week you
know no no it was a lot harder yeah and
the views counted for like a lot more
and the AdSense was much better back
then yeah yeah it was way different so
yeah so for that six mil in a week I get
hit up by every mediality you know CNN
NBC MTV ESPN you know so for you like
like that was kind of did you realize at
that point in time that there was the
real money was being a content creator
uh it started to be clear it started to
be clear yeah yeah uh
you know I was just thinking such like a
Hooper though you know like back in the
am one day when it ended and all that I
was just thinking like
you know am I still pursuing the NBA
where am I gonna hoop now am I going to
overseas green kids going to G League
yeah not knowing as I'm uploading I'm
doing my job
we're good you know but it took a viral
Spike to turn it into a business like
real fast you know what I'm saying
you're like oh this is this is it this
is it yeah and I thought about it even
back in the day when I first heard about
YouTube because I knew it was in a few
other countries because internationally
they'd recognize us from it and I
remember saying to myself I'm like oh
this is like TV this is like it's a new
TV I said free distribution but
then when it came to fruition as a
business I'm like oh literally it's TV
like like way higher than you know we
never thought it'd be like today right
it's like the go-to but what about Tick
Tock when did uh Tick Tock really take
off for you because you got a [__] ton
of followers trying to go crazy on Tick
Tock yeah it's quick could you can you
make money on tick tock
I know that like you can you can get it
like when it's monetized I've had people
tell me call me Mark makes money once
you monetize your Tick Tock they start
[__] with your algorithm no okay
here's the truth you don't really make
it's like YouTube shorts you don't
really you don't make much because the
YouTube shorts you'll be like I got I
got a interview clip that has like three
million uh views and I think I made
nothing 29 yeah something like that yeah
I've been doing 30 million who made like
not a couple like yeah right it's like
what do we do it yeah yeah no my Tick
Tock I got uh three and a half billion
views and I made eight thousand dollars
so it pays a little more in YouTube
shorts but yeah
for your YouTube channel kinda right
yeah and my commercial for your brand
yeah and we went when I started to take
off on YouTube and pressing the social
media I started realizing the value like
early you should be on every platform
everything anything that drops I sign up
for the name like just in case you know
yeah and when it's new press in and go
hard because you know they're pushing
everything like so uh with YouTube I
think I was actually a year late to you
uh to tick tock yeah to be honest but
once I got onto my first video I didn't
put no effort in I got like five and a
half million views it was on Halloween I
was dressed as the Joker my cousin was
Batman so the The Joker movie song was
trending yeah so we just did I did a
little dribble as the Joker like nothing
not even anything nothing crazy yeah but
it just went crazy like five and a half
million views I was like oh there might
be something here guess I should use it
yo it's crazy because you watch like um
I just watched uh the White Men Can't
Jump video uh a movie with Jack Harlow
uh which was actually a lot better than
I thought it was gonna be
um
do you ever have you ever had a point in
time where you were hustling people at
the park
oh I live white man can't jump today
like still I know you do it on on like
Tick Tock where you like show up like
dressed as like a McDonald's employee or
something yeah but I mean like when the
cameras aren't rolling like maybe you're
in a different city or you're like you
know what let's oh I see what you're
saying now okay have you ever like
pulled up to the park and been like I'm
gonna just it's almost like being a pool
shark right it's like well somebody
there is Gonna Know Me Now now they will
yeah but you've never done that in in
like ever oh just period just hustled
somebody out of somebody at the park
because they just assume you're like the
the geeky white dude and well I grew up
doing it I mean I feel like I grew up
doing that literally and then up until
I don't know I think as of like 2015
though you're too famous yeah I only
play if we're rolling for you the Vlog
if we're on for social media like I
won't even do open runs or nothing only
because of injury risk though you know
39 right now yeah yeah you get hurt then
you can't do your grind it actually
doesn't make any sense the older I get
it's just like the league right you're
not playing too much outside though
that's what I tell everybody like it's
really easy to watch
the big three and be like he still got
it like yeah he still got it for a half
court game yeah once a week but I don't
know if he's still got it for 82 games
it's a lot different right people have a
lot of spin past the normal like hooping
age but you're right that 82 games is
brutal like I just saw Jay Rich get up
at big three and like almost hit his
head on the [__] rim
again yes but can he sustain being
healthy for a whole season you know it's
hard but like for like it's hard for me
to stay healthy doing YouTube yo it's
crazy you know what I mean but it's been
good and and honestly like that's the
cool Parts my Lane is kind of unexplored
because
once you're about 35 playing in League
rights too many miles for your body it's
gonna be hard for you to sustain unless
you're like a Vince Carter or Lebron you
know world-class athlete but for me like
where are you done a Salesman who you
know it's kind of like oh he kept going
he's kind of like a coach yeah no but I
mean hey Badoo was it was an insane
athlete right same athlete yes and one
of the guys you did not want to throw
hands with in the league oh yeah true
story it's like him and Zebo growing up
like I don't know if he would ever want
to fight either one of those guys yeah
yeah but you know for me I feel like I'm
just as quick as I was in 05 like it's
crazy because you could have went like
you probably could have went a few
different directions right you might
have could have went to Chris Brickley
Direction and like trained guys and he's
done a good job of like doing content
and also like obviously training players
but kills it yeah I think like the
YouTube wave is I mean it's it's it's it
man yeah I love I love entertaining like
entertainment production even acting
I've acted for 20 years I never had like
heavy prominent roles what movies have
you been in well I was recent that
hustle you know Adam Sandler is that
like Cameo yep uh what's what's the
guy's name the [__] the dude
that looks like you kind of oh you're
talking about the lead here
what's his name something Gomez
yeah some shot him it's a dick no it's
not even that I'm blinking I'm blinking
but you know it's something it's
something Gomez it starts with an honest
it's it's
I I know he has honcho it's it's honcho
or juancho is his name herna Gomez
Hernan Gomez yeah okay I know his last
name I don't know his first name there's
juancho juancho or honcho you know he's
a cool cat man I feel like he's my bro I
should know his name Anthony Edwards is
a great actor too but they both did
their yeah they super did their thing in
that that was really dope um other other
films I've been in like like when I say
acting I've been like 50 to 100
commercials for any brand every brand
you can think of but then also uh I
first moved to la06 I actually had a
lead role in the movie It's called ball
don't lie and it never got released
damn that's got to be tough did you get
paid for it I got paid for it yeah but
not much you know indie film right but
you're like damn I just want it for me
can I get it on a do you have it on DVD
or something yeah I do have it but we're
trying to release it today we're trying
to get it released now I've met up with
those producers for the first time in
like 15 years yeah why not put it on 2B
or something that was our thought yeah
just for the resume yeah like dude and
we made the movie like yeah it's not
like it's gonna lose it like unless it's
like horrible and you're gonna get
canceled because you're shot at a no six
and you know no I mean we're not gonna
win no Awards but it's not horrible no
yeah good basketball yeah yeah but um
they've been making some good basketball
movies recently yeah a lot more too
because he used to only get a bass when
we were every few years I just watched
this one on Disney plus with my kids
about an Asian dude trying to dunk
was it good it was actually not I never
said I didn't even hear about this on
Disney plus today it's about this Asian
kid who goes viral on YouTube trying to
uh document the process of him trying to
dunk because he has a bet with another
kid at his high school dunk huh and then
he ends up faking
him dunking for the YouTube viewers but
then he gets close out for and he has to
apologize oh it's actually really good
it's a Disney Original I gotta check it
out oh it's Disney wow yeah this I'm
telling I'm telling you you guys you and
this other [__] guy we just talked
about you guys are making this
basketball [__] like popping a whole
different way bro trying to man trying
to go for it I'm actually trying to hoop
till 2034 50 years old yeah that I mean
you could probably go to 60. because
then guess what that oh really that's
what that means well that's that's a
YouTube title 60 year old break some
guy's ankle at the park it's like the
real Uncle Drew oh for real gotta stop
the interview to say about our good
Folks at Odd Socks baby yeah shout out
to odd talks now this is what I love
about Odd Socks one their family we love
them but also they have the most
comfortable socks in the [__] world
all right now look they got the craziest
licenses you see the Jolly Rancher these
are actually flies [__]
some Dorito socks uh they got the WWE
license which is just my absolute
favorite and then um personally my
favorite is the odd Sox Basics now these
are just the basic socks so these are in
my bag because I'm taking these
I love these odd Sox basics
these are literally the most comfortable
socks in the world
all right these are just the plain guys
all right also they got the Scarface
they got the Godfather and they have
underwear
what are we talking about what are these
2XL Reese's Pieces you know if uh
somebody was gonna wear some Reese's
underwear I'd assume they'd be a 2x on
the size you know shots of the
Ghostbusters
um look so much going on at Odd Socks uh
what you got to do is go to
oddsoxofficial.com use that promo code
bootleg and you will save 20 off at
checkout all right it don't matter what
you're into they got all the licenses
Coca-Cola you could be a Pepsi guy
instead they got both you know what I'm
saying uh you're into maybe some anime
they got all the anime licenses they got
Naruto they also got um they just uh uh
rolled out the new uh Power Rangers
Transformers all that oddsoxofficial.com
use the promo code bootleg save 20 off
right now oh my goodness let me tell you
something the best part about my bookie
is not only is it the best sports book
period I mean look we're in the middle
of baseball season and baseball season
is Big Money season if you are a gambler
you know baseball is where you get the
Shmoney all right not only that but they
got the full-fledged casino going on all
right I'm telling you last night I'm on
my bookie I'm playing roulette with a
lady I'm looking at the lady she's on
video she's rolling the wheel it's a
movie all right they got Blackjack they
got uh whatever you're into Blackjack
craps oh man all kinds of slots some of
these slot games are so fun all right
listen everything you want all on one
site mybookie.ag this is the best part
when you sign up with our promo code
bootleg not only do you help us out but
you help yourself out because you're
gonna get that first deposit bonus money
to gamble with immediately free once you
sign up
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
get the first deposit bonus right now
let's get back into the interview for
you like how do you TR like like are you
pretty Health conscientious are you like
obviously you're not running you know
full court runs outside of being on film
but are you like making sure that you're
taking the precautions to not you know
be injured oh yeah I'm training a lot
yeah I try Super Active so train twice a
week with like functional movement
training uh a lot of core stuff it's
like the same kind of training you still
look like you're [__] 18 by the way
humble man they say hey they say black
don't crack gingers don't crack
my goodness we're trying man we're
trying thank you bro um but no yeah
functional movement training I live in
Marina I run on the water like three
times a week and then I hoop on top of
that so if we're going hooping the
functional movement training plus
running it's a lot very active on a
weekly basis so even if you don't hoop
that much you still got to stay moving
you gotta that's one key to longevity is
just like even if you run and you don't
get a good cardio sweat in at least you
moved movement you just got to stay
doing it can't take long breaks yeah for
sure yeah I was gonna say back in the
day Peak and one
was there ever any sort of like
because I because I you guys were were
super hot man and I always wondered how
like guys in the actual League felt
about y'all was ever any like obviously
yeah I'm sure there was like love but
was there any like haters in the NBA
that just like like was everything like
[__] and one NBA beefs going on that
yeah I think yeah there was a little bit
you know what's funny I'm shooting a
video tomorrow talking about this exact
subject right here like no lie I I was
on kg's podcast like a couple weeks ago
yep and we had a little a snippet came
out on Instagram about it and it likes I
didn't see yeah it went crazy what was
kg's hand he was basically saying some
of my teammates uh they were eating
dinner somewhere at a restaurant New
York and the topic came up of them you
know getting at the NBA players and kg
he was like man he's like I was about
that I wanted to see what's good you
know I mean obviously they're in the
league at that time
like some like unfilmed super game where
like Kevin Kevin Garnett and like
[__] Stefan Marbury show up to like a
park in Harlem at 3 A.M
no you know what's crazy though when
half man have amazing was gassing that
up though back in the day like think
about it we were on TV more than the NBA
right the ESPN
think if they actually did that game
actually was for real like that would
have like we might have had to have a
think about we sold out the garden just
and one game right so what would have
and one versus NBA All-Star Game Crazy
and just a theory a theory game
especially in like 0-304 oh my goodness
might need a football stadium oh man
half man we're just talking about that
yeah it's crazy to think like you know I
I'm just glad to see because you know
when I was a kid man the basketball was
so
and it's big now but it's just dope to
see like today's generation have
whatever version of like and one was to
me to them you know what I'm saying
that's why I'll try to keep it going you
know because you probably have such a
wide range of fans oh super because you
have like guys that are like me who is
old and watch you as when I was a kid
and then you got like my [__]
nine-year-old knows exactly who you are
I showed him he's like oh you're gonna
interview him he's at basketball camp
right now otherwise he'd probably be
here but oh you know it's crazy you have
like such a what like it's probably hard
for you to go too many places without
getting stopped yeah oh no yeah for sure
it's a blessing though like if I look at
my analytics it's like 20 18 and under
twenty percent eighteen to thirty five
twenty percent thirty five and up I even
got people 55 and up there's a 10 you
know so yeah it's a blessing to have a
wide demographic of doing it just for a
long time um for you uh obviously so you
want to ball to your 50 but what are
other things you're trying to like do to
kind of just expand like the Empire yeah
obviously you got merch you got stuff
you're selling but like give me kind of
the breakdown on mobile hooper.com
global hooper.com
yeah so uh when you talk about expansion
I'm actually trying to produce a movie
of my life story where I play myself so
I've been working out on that for a
couple of years they get that film soon
because you're still young the strike
don't help you know what I'm saying the
strikes [__] everything it's not
helping but uh except for 2B yeah
they're two maybe you know I think I
think you can still get a 2B movie off
and the SAG won't be mad I'm in sad yeah
I don't know so if you're in Sag you
should not you're on strike you are on
strike I heard they're like gay it's
like gang [__] like you cannot cross the
strike yeah it's real it's real it's
real so um so now we respect and all
that but you know trying to put more of
a foot into the acting world I don't
think I'd ever stop my YouTube channel
just because like you've seen even
A-list Stars a influencers also and I've
seen even like big YouTubers go
mainstream or do something mainstream
and then have to come back to YouTube
yeah it happens actually a lot then the
algorithm is all messed up it's not like
it was before so I don't I don't ever
want to let up off the gas personally I
just think man controlling your own
narrative is a beautiful thing you're
Your Own Boss over there if people don't
want to give you work elsewhere you
still got that and it's it is TV like
the number one used app on my TV is
YouTube yeah I mean his number one
streaming app in the world in fact I'm I
don't care about like I don't watch
Netflix unless like some show drops like
I just watched quarterbacks okay but I'm
always on YouTube my kids are on YouTube
yeah me too me too if I'm not if I'm not
watching Netflix it's YouTube So yeah so
you're essentially you're like you want
to just kind of dip your toe into like
producing like original content or being
a part of like movies on a bigger scale
yeah as well as still keeping your foot
on the mainly acting a little bit of
producing yeah for sure but also for me
it's funny as long as I've gone you know
start my YouTube channel 09 the weakness
of my brand has actually always been
infrastructure I didn't upload enough
and now as we get further into it people
upload way way more yeah I was gonna say
how often are you uh are you dropping
content now we're gonna go four to six
times a month but I've always had I've
always been like kind of like Mr Beast
where you take a lot of time for video
treated like a TV show where
everything's perfect good sound amazing
concept you're aiming to break the
internet but we sometimes we only get
one or two of a month right and
don't get me wrong it's good like I
think there's a more a better from a
business standpoint what's your most
viewed YouTube video
uh 83 mil views but what what what were
you doing oh I went to Laguna Beach and
I played a trash talker it was actually
the first my first Trash talker video I
came up with that that turn the trash
talk yeah uh dude was just talking crazy
I was I had been up there for like three
hours of playing at the Laguna courts
you know in Laguna Beach and um
this dude came up and he was just
he's trying to discredit Everything I
did and then he knew exactly who you
were
I don't think he did so he didn't know I
don't think so maybe maybe but I don't
think so so then he was like giving the
dude a hard time that was guarding Me
Maybe he knew them but he kept he kept
saying after every bucket I would get
like man you gotta do this do this and
he's like all you got to do is watch his
hips and so uh he's like man I got next
and I was like I said something like
well maybe we should get a ones in he's
like yeah let's get the ones in so I was
like all right cool so we finished that
game and I was like all right man you
trying to do it and then we matched up
one on one
he was a little bit heavy set though hmm
so Midway through the gang a little
winded did a move went between his legs
snatched it I didn't even touch him he
smacked he like smack hit the pavement
right
then like two plays later I did
somewhere up faked between my legs
between his legs snatch it he broke his
shoulder he like he like reached and
threw his shoulder out of the socket
so the game did that's why I got 83 Mill
views the game didn't even end we
couldn't have wrote a better script holy
[__] yeah so so when we edit it we go to
the edit we told the story of how the
game happened because that was one of my
critiques that I don't play good enough
competition right it's like I play
anybody in the streets rainbow so we
told a story of why that game went down
but then we realized oh like you gotta
do this every video you got to tell us
yeah tell the story to go with the thumb
was a zoom in to the ankle breaker so it
kind of that laid the it that paved the
way for how I need to do videos and even
the title I had money in the title yeah
I played a game for 100 bucks or
whatever it's trash talker wow yeah 83
million yeah I think that was 2016.
that's fully uh monetized oh for sure
2016 that's for sure yeah yeah a
lifetime analytics on there nice is it
safe to say you've surpassed your ann1
pay as a YouTuber by like 10 or 30 times
by now yeah I was going I was going
somewhere around 20 times I mean not to
get in your pockets but back in the day
like what was what was the pay decent
like like if you guys were hitting the
road it was decent yeah I don't mind I
think my first contract ever with that
one 18 years old was like 70k 60 70k not
bad for an 18 year old kid
professionally playing Hoops back then
before inflation hit the [__] not bad
yeah it wasn't bad but then as we went
it went big so we did you know
multi multi-year six-figure deals like
by the time I left I think I signed a
250k a year yeah 250k or something last
year but then we would make money
outside of A1 too so you could go do
that then you could go do oh I'm gonna
go do an appearance or I'm gonna go play
in a game in China or Africa yeah so I
think my last year
I think one of the years I made 800k or
something like that and so that was cool
but just hooping just hooping just I
think we made millions of dollars the
whole run the whole run of course but
I'm just saying like for a single year
for a single year I was like awesome I
thought I was rich I thought my money
would never run out was was uh
everyone's pay scale is different do you
know or like because obviously there's
bigger names smaller names like because
I I think when I think again when I
think of you I think a hot sauce I think
I think Escalade uh I think of uh half
and a half amazing I think of uh who
else and you're probably different you
watched it you know the casuals they say
like me hot sauce and then it's either
like skip or Escalade yeah maybe AO
yeah AO was dope yeah yeah yeah damn
that's crazy yeah damn yeah but no it's
based on marketability and skill so like
what you bring to the table on the court
play to role but then obviously your
marketability so I'm sure like hostiles
had the biggest deal I was like skip was
already in the NBA but like you know I'm
sure hot sauce had the biggest house I
was AO Maine when you saw Ray for Austin
make it to the league are you like it
ain't over for me he still made it hey
let's stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our good Folks at King
Palm that's right man shout out to King
Palm uh we're talking about nothing but
that organic all right that natural
Them Leafs all right there's no tobacco
involved and they're so smooth when you
smoke in them I love King Palms the only
thing I'm smoking out of now if you go
to your local uh liquor store you go to
your local smoke shop you can get King
Palms of course 7-Eleven's got the king
pongs and they have so many crazy
flavors like shout out to Sugar Shawn
who's from um
Phoenix Arizona my hometown he's got his
own flavor they just sent us these now
what's dope about King Palm is that they
have the the terpene infused flavors so
at the end of the tip of these pre-rolls
right you get the Leaf
you squeeze the tip that's what she said
and then you just get a burst of flavor
this is that honey mango all right now
this is the most important part this is
absolutely natural
tobacco-free leaves the cleanest way to
smoke all right trust me when I say it
man we love King Palm over here so many
flavors I mean shout out to the grape
shots of the honey mango shout out to
the sugar punch right here you know what
I'm saying look if you go to kingpom.com
right now you can get hooked up with
everything you need at 50 off if you use
the promo code bootleg
or bootleg Kev try either one of those I
forget which one it is it's bootleg or
it's bootleg Kev you know what the
correct promo code will be down below
use the one that's down here kingpom.com
get 50 off right now shout out to King
pong
also want to shout out to our good Folks
at Blue chew baby shout out to Bluetooth
now this was going on with Bluetooth man
everybody keeps asking me this Bluetooth
work yes it works but don't take my word
for it you're gonna get a month for free
when you go to bluetooth.com and you use
the promo code bootleg a month for free
now what is Bluetooth fellas if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction fellas
if your dick is not getting as hard as
you'd like it to maybe for your wife oh
I don't know listen all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com it has the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but it's getting delivered to you in a
chewable form right to your door in
discreet packaging and you do not have
to go into a doctor's office to get
Bluetooth you go to bluetooth.com you
use the promo code bootleg you get a
month supply delivered to your door
discretely of course
discreetly
no doctor's appointments no going in
leaving your house and sitting in a
Lobby and waiting for some you know lady
to call you in so you could tell her how
your cock's not working properly it
happens fellas all right bluetooth.com
take my word for it also take their word
for it because they're gonna give you a
month's supply for free just five dollar
shipping bluetooth.com promo code
bootleg uh let's get back to the
interview
yeah there were a lot of people like
that
because he kind of kicked the door down
for the possibility to like be as like a
legendary Street baller so his was
different though so he actually played
all he went the regular ride just played
street balls in the Summer Okay so we're
like full-time street ball like I let go
of school so his thing was he was still
going to school he was still doing
everything summer time it was he played
Community College right Fresno State got
drafted a little D-League then came back
up didn't sign a big deal a few big
deals but yeah uh
for The Other Guys
I mean anything's possible but I think a
lot of guys just didn't get that
opportunity or like
there maybe was some shortcoming whether
it was on the court or off or
everybody's story is a little bit
different but dudes were good enough to
be that's the myth man they did that
documentary they did a doc on and one
last year on ESPN there's two docs
there's one on ESPN and one on Netflix
the one on ESPN had NBA players kind of
like bashing I don't even know why this
was in the dock if it's there and one
doc yeah but they were like bashing the
level of play of and one players and uh
it wasn't a good narrative like it
wasn't true why do the documentary if
you're gonna bash us I didn't get it
yeah I didn't understand it I don't know
but luckily most people saw the Netflix
stuff yeah um it's crazy too because I
think like
back then like there had to have been
like
for you guys like to hit the like what
was was y'all did y'all have like and
one groupies was there like chicks like
it was like [__] because you know
what the dog is that was a thing it was
hip hop it was a rock star hip hop
basketball tour yes
you guys had rappers on tour too right
or was it different city everybody did
the halftimes like like okay remember
you're just saying Cassidy was up here
he was doing but it was like Dip set the
locks uh I think when I saw it it was uh
David Banner and Roscoe David Banner
killed it bro oh my God Jackson
Mississippi is home it was wild listen I
always say this because I've I've always
watched guys do halftime shows and
they'd be like it's a little different
people are getting up to go to like get
their drinks but I'm like listen oh this
is lit I saw David Banner do a halftime
show and he was alone standing in the
middle of the court and he shut that
[__] the [__] down shut it down ain't
got up on the rim once it's like sat on
the rim it's crazy but uh no those
halftimes went off E40 actually killed
her like when we did the bay with the
Bay Area I play Oakland
I remember E40 came on there and uh oh
what was it there was these other dudes
though
some local group it was like he
Federation yeah they hit the court and
everybody ran the court and they had to
stop it because it got it was like fire
high fever man yeah exactly a high fear
that was crazy but every halftime for
and one was like super turned up what
about uh what do you think about Big
Three
oh I think it's dope I love it I love it
I mean
I don't think like some people might
call that like stream I don't really
view it as like Streetball necessarily
but I think that like you're right guys
have more spin after the league you know
saying you might be good in the half
court so you're 50 like you're saying so
so I think it's another uh it's another
Outlet to check out I feel like it was
funny ice cube was saying he felt like
The Gatekeepers are kind of like
stopping it I have seen that yet and I
feel like that too because he doing all
the mainstream media I think that it
would benefit from having some headline
players though that that uh
maybe could turn up from a hit from a
highlight standpoint that's what I think
I was gonna say like when Iverson and
Jay will win
yeah that was ready to go berserk yeah
and then yeah because that made me want
to watch I was like wait white chocolate
and AI which is tough I'm in yeah me too
but the hard thing was like so Jay will
he was very played we got injured right
so because he never came back after that
did he ever play at all maybe a game or
two we blew out his knee and then uh I
knew AI you know I played Iverson's last
game he ever played like I played with
him in China it was a three-game tour
it's on my my YouTube channel really
yeah it was fire but uh because that was
my guy what year was that
2012. wow so his kind of farewell tour
in China you were you were there yeah
2012. and well the last time he actually
took to the court and played a full game
but uh
so I knew but he barely wanted to do
that and then after that he never played
again so I knew when the big three was
talking about he's hooping I was like
are you sure people like to play like
that because at the end of the day like
you play on Iverson's level where like
those NBA All-Star even like me talking
to kg right
they ain't trying to the stakes are too
low it feels weird like going to play in
a game at a half full Arena or like if I
asked kg would you collab on my you he
gonna be like nah like why like he's
already cemented that dude's Hall of
Fame not uh it's crazy have you ever
hooked or messed around with uh with
Jason Williams at all with Jay will
cause he's obviously kind of like the
you know when you were a kid watching
him and Vince and it was like that era
like three ball in the league oh my God
yeah crazy yeah Iverson Jay will like
you said that was crazy yeah
um we're trying to make it happen we're
actually trying to make it happen so I
did a collab video with him he came to
our studio downtown I have like a half
court LED setup
we just talk Hoops he showed me his
elbow pass I shot an elbow past it yeah
I showed him a move I do just got his
thoughts on it and then um
we've been trying to re so I got I
actually had a little injury but we've
been trying to revisit doing a Who video
and he said he was down so like if you
guys went to the park or something I
told him we'll break the internet just
go break the internet real quick yes
it'd be crazy yeah so we trying we're
trying did they ever approach you to try
to play in like the big three
by the way maybe they'd be smart too
they asked me
to enter the draft but I noticed that
skip was in the draft he didn't get
picked so like I wasn't gonna introduce
well he didn't get picked skip was in
the draft and didn't yeah some of the
guys who got I mean listen no disrespect
to a lot of those guys but I remember
just I'm talking we're talking about
selling tickets putting seats and asses
here yeah and maybe skip didn't want to
play I didn't know the details right but
I just like I remember seeing some of
the guys and I'm just like
yeah I mean Rashad McCants was like a
fringe like make it on a roster kind of
guy and I know he's like one of the main
big three guys but it's like I don't
know who's coming out to see we're
trying to cancel you know that yeah for
a little bit you know it's tough yeah
you need to highlight guys
you need somebody to yeah you need the
tick tock guys hey what's the Reel
that's gonna go crazy to promote the big
three yeah but they're not good enough
you know I'm saying you gotta play at
that higher level we're like you're
trying to keep it big boy you know just
below the NBA competition level I didn't
want to do it because like my thing was
like they're giving other dudes deals
well you mean enter the draft that's
just from marketing so you can like I'm
saying it yeah like I'm the most popular
guy
following wise here literally outside of
J Will and Iverson that would have been
100 yeah so like I wasn't gonna do it
unless somebody with Simon but then also
let me play how I play yeah okay travel
a chip in the late like the three yeah I
feel like they could benefit a lot from
some entertainment I know even like Bone
Collector and white chocolate went and
went through the combine didn't get
picked up
so they're keeping it tight they're
keeping it like real yeah I get what
he's trying to do he's trying to
essentially set up a situation where you
can extend your career yeah yeah exactly
he's trying to say this is a big boy
League you know top level competition
still it's just like just below the NBA
when you're done you go here yeah yeah
which I respect but yeah I didn't want
to do it just to me it didn't feel right
like I'm not gonna you know
go to a team and be on the bench the
whole game or like because you know when
you get into those
like the personas are like
how the coach and the big three would
look at it and how serious them dudes
want a championship if I don't go
between the legs I'm gonna kick that out
they're gonna be mad you know what I
mean it's like
we gotta take him out yeah too but I'll
get some moves I'll be trying to do
moves I'll be trying to turn it out you
know what I mean but yeah they're trying
to get the crowd what team would be cool
with that for sure maybe it's maybe but
is Ice Cube cool who knows yummy I saw
you did a video with uh with Paul George
like how are your relationships with
some of the guys in the NBA nowadays
like obviously you're a celebrity
celebrity like you know outside of just
being the OG and one guy you know what
I'm saying we're cool I mean a lot of
guys are busy right so like I don't
necessarily like hang with NBA players
but I feel like I've met almost
everybody you know and everybody just
shows a lot of love I show a lot of
respect uh to those guys for doing it at
the highest level but Paul George is
awesome man I never met him before that
day we shot that video that shit's crazy
so did you uh did you do did you end up
going to uh did you go to NBA con at all
I was out there for summer league I
didn't go to NBA con I should have
summer League's [__] fire I had a
great time yeah I love it I had a good
time I went to like summer league one of
the one of the days it was the day after
when Manana had his his uh it was like a
slower day because my sons were playing
okay and uh I just dude we were there
all day and like met everybody's just
walking around like everybody yeah the
players will get done playing and then
walk around the arena like I know you
don't notice that like we we left the
arena yeah and then like dudes who just
played that game right next to us we're
like
what the it's crazy they didn't have a
VIP tunnel over here nah and then they
have the two games going on like
simultaneously because they kind of have
the two connected Arenas it's
it's mine I I told my uh my boy I was
like next year we're gonna do like a
week of this [__] that's what we did I
did about four days we're gonna go out
there it's gonna be like our all-star
weekend because I don't [__] with
All-Star week it's too much drama you
know I'm saying I'm good let me go to
[__] It's Crazy Summer League it's
crazy we go hang out be a basketball
geek it's turning into the summertime
NBA though it is it's like a wave for
the NBA and everybody around the NBA to
exist yeah for the summer for a little
bit 100 it's like two weeks it's crazy
it is it is two weeks but it's really
about that first like
week yeah we missed the wave like my
homie he was here he was there like when
wimby was playing crazy we came three
days after and caught like the last
weekend and don't get me wrong it was
still lit but it was it wasn't like the
first weekend it's crazy because because
a lot of those main draft picks you know
they play a game or two and then they
get set you know it's like
and then they got guys like uh what's
what's the guy's name Jabari Smith on
the [__] Rockets
okay okay oh
shout out to my sons yeah yeah it's
still good basketball regardless when
you go short
um well look man uh obviously you got a
lot a lot going on people can go follow
you on Tick Tock they go on the YouTube
channel yes sir Instagram what's
happening what's the handle everywhere
is it just yeah Professor live YouTube
and Facebook the professor on everything
else check it out globalcooper.com you
got a Snapchat show yet
yes check it out Professor live Snapchat
Snapchat money is good it is good
nobody's complaining listen we just we
just launched a Snapchat show like uh
two months ago and like first month
booming going off Snapchat would be
confusing though there's like the shows
and there's the story I have no idea
because I don't somebody run it for you
right yes some dude in London you're
smart my guy Dean in London handles all
of it and he's like here's the analytics
this is how much we're on Pace to make
and I'm like oh I actually outsourced
that I don't have the app on my phone
yeah I don't have it I don't have I
should keep track I don't have Snapchat
on my phone okay yeah I haven't had it
on my phone for I don't even know how
long okay you're gonna chop this up and
then you know yeah yeah let's go man
there it is man the professor I
appreciate you buddy hey man honors
thanks for having me on appreciate you
boom yeah fire
hey this interview is brought to you by
our good Folks at hardean all right
shout out to the hardeen family in Las
Vegas make sure you follow them Harding
underscore Las Vegas the number one
dispensary period all right the craziest
selection of previous premium cannabis
you could ask for plus when you go to
hardinlasvegas.com you can check out all
the other cool stuff they got going on
you know they got a whole weed
University happening in Vegas hardine is
where it's at all right so if you're in
Las Vegas you get into that taxi cab you
say take me to Jardine and when you get
there you tell them wonderful Bud
tenders that I sent you and they're
gonna take care of you Harding
underscore Las Vegas go follow them and
uh yeah we got another interview coming
soon